колеги я думаю що вам знайомі ці
прізвища кадрової нечисті яка закликає
регулярно багато років поспіль до
окупації України знищення українців
зачистки українського простору такі як
Басков і Кіркоров Дейв і Києва Повалій
крутой Царьов Азіров Ани Лорак ну і цей
перелік можуть продовжити окремі
представники нечисті які так само чомусь
досі знаходяться у цій залі хоча їхній
партії заборонені На жаль багато більш
ті люди яких я назвала і великий список
інакших Вони мають державні нагороди
герої України завеликі всякі заслуги і
на жаль моїх ніяк не можемо позбавити
їхніх звань Ми з паном микитою
потураєвом з колегами комітету
гуманітарної та інформаційної політики
мало нещо комітету відправляємо
звернення на Міністерство будь ласка
позбавте ту всю нечисть а державних
нагород А нам розказують що у нас немає
достатніх підстав тому Шановні колеги я
дуже прошу підтримати цей законопроект
задля того щоб ми отримали можливості і
механізми позбавити нагород тих людей
які уже давно зрадили Українську державу
на жаль зараз механізми виписані Так що
немає можливості цього зробити а до
другого читання цей законопроект треба
буде ще доопрацювати і внести певні
корективи Але я маю надію що після
голосування уже в остаточно ми зможемо
очистити нашу державу Ну і так само я
Закликаємо на більшість і керівництво
Верховної Ради якомога швидше винести в
сесійну залу законопроєкти які
заборонять Московську фсбшну церкву і
заборонять нарешті на різних рівнях
влади представників
від заборонених партій які якогось
бізнесу ще досить